non-commutated constraint satisfaction
problems
I have stories
yeah
right so non-commodative csps
hey everyone uh I'm hamun uh uh I'm
really glad to be here I just started my
postdoc at the quantum pod here
um and uh finish my uh PhD not too long
ago and I'm going to tell you a little
bit about my thesis uh
uh so you're all familiar with uh
constraint satisfaction problems and how
they uh our Central Topic in in
theoretical computer science so I'm
going to tell you uh a non-commutative
variant of csps uh that uh that are
intensely studied in Quantum information
uh but the way I want to uh motivate
them for you is through their
relationship to classical CSV so if the
goal is really to understand classical
csvs like Max God I mean Max would be
understand very well but you know other
csps could we gain some insight into
them if we saw uh look at them through
the non-commutative
lens
um so I prepared a few examples through
which I will uh tell you what these
non-commutative csps look like and tell
you two really important open problems
about them that I would hope to see
solved
so the first one very simple uh country
satisfaction problem known as magic
square game uh we have a bunch of
variables nine variables arranged in
this Square uh three by three square and
each variable can take your value in in
the set minus one plus one and there are
a bunch of constraints so in particular
we want the rows and columns to multiply
to plus one except for the last column
where we want the product to be minus
one
and the question is can we uh
simultaneously satisfy these constraints
well a moment's thought shows that this
is really not possible so
we have contradiction suppose that we
could we could satisfy these constraints
uh then if we multiply these uh
variables row wise a row first you would
get plus one and if we do it column wise
we would get minus one and that's a
contradiction so we cannot
simultaneously satisfy these constraints
but what if
um what if we try to plug in instead of
uh scalars uh operators that mimic plus
one minus one so what are these
operators it would be unitary operators
if eigenvalues that are plus one but we
hope to solve this problem by uh trying
to plug in operators
so in particular we want the you know
product of rows and columns to be plus
identity operator or minus identity
operating
and uh well just a moment ago I gave you
this uh contradiction uh that was
working in the classic in the in the
case of scalars uh that same thing is
exactly is true here as well uh if we
try to multiply these products row wise
we get plus identity if you try to
multiply them column wise we get minus
identity but uh this is not a
contradiction for operators because the
order matters we could imagine a world
where product of some operators in some
order is plus identity and their product
in some other order is minus identity in
fact uh there is a concrete assignment
uh to these uh to these variables some
matrices that are four by four
dimensional the specifics of them
doesn't matter here I constructed them
from famous quality operators from
Quantum mechanic and uh that that will
satisfy the constraints perfectly okay
and
um so
um this this distinction the scalar
versus operator that that we could we
could you know solve this kind of
satisfaction problem perfectly in the
cons in the operator table and this
exact problem of magic square is at the
heart of many applications in Quantum uh
information a lot of quantum protocols
start by taking this magic square and
the fact that we can solve them in the
in the realm of operators perfectly uh
and we cannot solve do that in the
classical like it has a lot of
applications for example in cryptography
Quantum cryptography so
um now let me tell you about a second
example of non-commutative constraint
satisfaction problem so again we're
going to start with uh with classical uh
setting uh it's it's a Max cut we're all
familiar with it uh the the goal is to
find a card that has uh that has the
largest number of edges crossing the cut
right uh let's I mean we've all seen the
formulation of Max got in terms of
polynomials uh let's just remind
ourselves in this formulation we would
have assigned to every vertex a variable
x i that can take values plus one or
minus one and uh doing so would allow us
to have this indicator expression here
uh that would take value one
if and only if the ex the the assignment
to Xin X3 are distinct and it would take
value zero otherwise okay with this uh
it's not too difficult to see that
the max gut is really the optimization
of this uh polynomial subject to the
constraint that the variables are plus
one
and now just like magic square the
recipe for turning this into a
non-commutative constant satisfaction
problem is exactly uh the same as before
uh let's just plug in instead of
variables uh these are scalars that
would take plus minus one uh let's um
plugging unitaries that have
eigenvectors plus minus one
and uh and and we ask what would be the
optimal or the the maximum maximum of
the trace of such a uh such an
expression that we would obtain by
plugging of uh possible uh unitaries for
x i and X3
uh then you might say in the case of
maxcad we had this very nice
visualization we understand what you
know it's a card and we are counting the
edges when we are assigning operators we
don't have that visualization
but still uh uh I hope you trust me that
this has a really meaningful interpret
uh operational interpretation in Quantum
information yes
you still have a graph exactly the
instance is you know is the underlying
instance is the graph
it's the same for classical and Quantum
it's just that in the quantum case you
take the polynomial and you try to plug
in unit change right and it would have a
really meaningful operational
interpretation and uh you know a simple
example of this this problem is actually
something that physicists use day to day
to calibrate their Quantum devices uh
it's a a that simple example is called
chsh gain for example
um now um
but as computer scientists we want to
understand which one of these problems
is computationally harder that's the
first thing that we try to settle right
let's take a look at the problem the
classical problem classical Maxwell uh I
mean it's famously and be hard but it's
decidable right uh it's just finally
options uh in the non-commutative
version so there is no down that we're
putting on the size of this matrices
right they could be infinite dimensional
for all they know right so a priority it
seems that this problem could even be
undecidable and in fact this is true we
showed that in general non-community
polynomial optimization is is really
really hard it's even harder especially
harder than housing problem
whereas as I just mentioned uh the the
the the uh commutative polymer
optimization is always at least
decidable in peer space
okay but this is true in general
uh and
uh in this specif a specific example
actually uh it turns out the
non-competence problem is is uh uh is
easier than the classical one in fact
the non-communitive problem is a is a
semi-definite programming in Disguise
and we can solve it in polynomial time
uh whereas we cannot do this for Max
Cloud we cannot even approach hope to
approximate up to you know a constant uh
D Max a problem so so what is happening
like uh could we could we try to find
like uh a broader class of csps for
which uh this is true
um
in
in general for any CSV we could come up
with two different relaxations for it uh
just like the recipe that I gave uh so
far you could imagine the
non-commutative CSP right now you know
how to start from any CSP and try to
come up with analog and then there is
the basic STP that is a relaxation to
both of these commutative and
non-commeritive problems okay and we
have a beautiful theory in theory could
come to science that explains the gap
between the classical value and the STP
right that is very well understood very
well studied
but we don't have such a theory for
non-commutative services so that's what
uh one of the things we did uh we came
up with a tool that would allow us to
understand the gap between the
non-commutative value and sdp for some
classes of csps we can do this for csps
that are two variables two variable csps
where the equations or constraints are
just involving two variables at a time
and
um and something we call real real two
variables
yes
um and
um like for example uh using this Tool
uh a variant of Maxwell Problem X3 cut
the non-committed version of it is we
can show that it's it's not too far from
the value that you would get from
existing okay
um and um
yeah so I told you that this this tool
or only works for two variable csps
whereas the tool that we have for
classical CSV is like all those theories
work for any csps uh we know that for
example if you need games conjecture is
true the basic STP is always going to
give you the best approximation ratio
that you could hope uh for for csps for
classical sales we don't have such an
all-encompassing theory for
non-communition this was the first step
and we hope to be able to extend that
now uh
so that's that's one problem uh the
other problem is that so I told you that
there are these regimes it seems that
the where the non-committed problem is
easier than to solve than the
commutative one
would it be ideal that in these cases uh
we could extract
once we solve the non-committed problem
we could extract the classic a good
classical solution from this
non-commative solution could we hope to
do something like that uh just like how
in the classical Theory we could
take the STP solution and then uh relax
it or around it to a good uh classical
solution for this yes could we do that
for the non-committed uh solution uh to
show that yes we can do that for for Max
Scott and already in the case of Max
Cloud the proof is not JBL and we have
this overwhelming evidence uh numerical
evidence that uh for all these two real
two variable csvs uh this this in fact
is true we could always uh get a good uh
classical solution uh
um from from the non-committing solution
also
you're saying for Max cut
um
did you do you get a gas that is smaller
so the Gap is exactly the same as what
you get for classic for Maxwell for STP
for STP exactly it's 0.878 the
commencement option constant but the the
exciting thing is that this thing that
for which we don't have proof yeah uh
the the Gap is uh is much better than
what you would get classically also uh
we are not trying to we are not
repeating unit games conjunction what
happens is that the this this this
rounding technique at this point is not
efficient yeah uh it just tells you that
information theoretically there is
always a good classical solution hidden
in any non-commutative solution to this
you have some kind of empirical evidence
and a very valid stated uh kind of
conjecture that
we were only able to prove in the case
of Mexico so far and you need to only
look at small dimensional non-commutated
operators or do you need to go really
last to mention that's that's a problem
uh with why this uh at this point is not
efficient because the knockout
institution could very easily become uh
exponential size even in case of Max
Scott the you know we can we can solve
the problem optimally but it could be
two to the N where n is the number of
vertices
dimensional Matrix exactly
we have we have a small succinct uh
representations for them uh like so
they're a bit complexities are small but
there are huge matrices it's saying if
you can solve this uh CSP
which could be in Bihar yes
then yeah
it looks kind of like exactly you know I
mean I mean uh so we want to know what
is the gap between these two problems we
want to know like uh uh whether you know
uh like so far it seems that like uh uh
you know the point is that the
non-commitative solution is really
preserving a lot of extraction of the
classical problem that's why the Gap
seems to be shaking so and I think
that's an interesting viewpoint but and
at this point we don't know how to do it
but there are ways of like you know
around the technique uh involves
um sampling from a high random unitaries
and in Quantum information there are
ways to do this sampling for exponential
side matrices but but approximately
efficient
so that's kind of think about
any further questions
for those of us not well informed
what's the connection to can you give
her a one sentence the explanation of
what the connection is to Quantum
information yes uh
uh the non-competitive csvs
would capture the value of what's known
as non-local gains that are Central
Central you know objects of study and
Quantum information so it's for computer
scientists for us it's multi-prover
interactive rules so it's essentially uh
the the value of these non-competitive
problems would uh tell you what is the
success probability of the provers in a
multi-prover Interactive
so their approvers are allowed to be
Quantum yeah does that make sense like
classically it would uh match the
approvers where uh we don't have that we
restrict them to be classical tours
I had a question so for any CSP you have
a sort of a trivial constant Factor
approximation if the Rarity and the
domain is bounded absolutely is that
something similar the case for
non-commutative csps or are there
problems for which
we don't know that all right I think
that we you know for any csps we don't
even know whether this Gap would be zero
like we don't even uh you know there's
uh there's no general theory that would
tell us that like you know from from the
sap solution you can get not sdp at all
but just if I give you a non-communitive
CSP is there some simple way to get it
some
horribly horrible constant approximation
oh no we cannot even do that so that's
that's the famous result that came out I
think in 2021 uh the MIP story
even even the
modest about the approach okay uh it
would be
yeah
[Music]
for General csvs
so you mentioned that non-commutive Max
cut you can solve efficiently uh are
there other is that does anything very
special about Mexico or is there a large
family of such things so I said that we
have this tool to approve integrality
Gap for uh to for real two variable csps
but uh in the case of Max kick up
problems uh we know how to obtain this
integrated Gap efficiently
uh so we can go beyond next uh yeah
but I guess
so for all two csps the non-commutative
csps and STP that we can solve
efficiently is that right no foreign
class of two uh two variable csvs like
for example unit games are also two
variable csps we don't know how to solve
so already we know that non-commutative
unit games can be uh we can there are
approximation algorithms that go far
beyond uh what we could hope to get
classes because classically we have the
unique conjecture that tells us we
cannot do better than uh
we cannot tell the difference between
one minus Epsilon versus Epsilon
um
whereas uh
non-commutative that we can we can say
uh we can say much better much more we
don't have an approximation there is no
approximation ratio uh like the
algorithm does not give you an
approximation issue but it is enough to
uh review the unit games conjecture
non-commutative
does that make sense and Max kicker is
another class of two variable csps and
for those we know how to solve them
efficiently it's approximately
a quick question
is there a way to solve is there a way
to solve something using some Quantum
Computing some relaxation which you
cannot remember why only classical sdp
right
can you solve some relaxation for this
csps which is not
I have not thought about that that would
be super exciting uh coming up with the
quantum algorithm question
Quantum algorithms for Quantum problems
um okay thank you very much
yes one more Quantum talk
um for lunch